hey guys it's Justine and today I wanted
to do a video talking about some health
tech this is not something that I just
picked up this past week this is stuff
that I've had around the house that I've
been using for actually like a couple of
years now for me health tech is
obviously because I love technology and
I have been very focused on my health
the last few years so being able to
quantify myself and being able to have
that data and analytics all kind of put
together in an app and being able to
like see my progress or see if things
aren't going well so I'm gonna go
through with some of my favorite things
that I've been using and now more than
ever I feel like it's very important to
be kind of taking our health into our
own hands we need to be able to have
this data so that if something is going
wrong we actually have a history of this
data to be able to take to doctors and
say hey this is why I know something is
wrong because I've been tracking my
heart rate for the past five or six
years for me specifically on my Apple
watch and I know what my normal is most
people don't know what their normal
temperature is what their resting heart
rate is or any of these types of things
so that's why I want to make this video
and show you guys some of my favorite
things the first thing that I'm talking
about is Apple watch
obviously I'm a huge fan of the Apple
watch you're able to now take an ECG
this gives you some consistent heart
rate data throughout the day so right
now I can see that my lowest heart rate
was 54 and the highest it was 172 we
were able to track workouts
there's even sleep apps so you can track
your sleep on this but mostly what's
great about this is it will give you
alerts if your heart rate has dropped
too low or too high and you'll be able
to contact a doctor to try to assess if
anything is medically wrong and you can
go get help I know those alerts have
helped so many people or save so many
lives so I really do love being able to
have this with me and on at all times so
obviously you guys encima do tons an
Apple watch videos so we don't have to
go any further into that the next thing
I want to show you guys this says Nokia
but this is actually made by we things
long story short the company was we
things Nokia bought them and then we
thing has bought themselves back from
Nokia this is called the thermo
thermometer thermometer uses 16 infrared
sensors to take more than 4,000
measurements at the temporal artery for
accurate results it's super easy to use
you just run it right along your
forehead and I love that this will sync
to an app so you can have all of your
history of all of your temperatures so
I'm gonna take my
right now and that's basically it and
that's actually a little a little high
so I'm gonna go check my app it just
popped up with a notification I'm gonna
take it one more time
ninety nine four I mean that's what my
temperature is it's saying I don't have
a fever so that's good anything over a
hundred then we should start getting
concerned it's actually really warm in
this room as well but my average
temperature over the past several weeks
has been about ninety eight obviously
I'm not a medical professional but I
think it's really great to be able to
have all of this stuff and be able to
track so that you'll be able to have
these trends so that again if there is
something that might be wrong you'll be
able to assess it immediately the
unfortunate reality is due to everything
that's happening right now I feel like a
lot of these gadgets are out of stock
but there's a lot of them that are
available for pre-order so you can get
on a list but I know this one is
extremely hard to get I couldn't find
any other ones online going along with
that same note also says Nokia but this
is made by we things currently I did
just order a new version of this one
online but it is due to arrive in the
next few days so I look forward to
checking that one out this is an older
model obviously because it does say
Nokia but this is a blood pressure
monitor so we're gonna take my blood
pressure now this also uses an app
called health mate and in addition to
this I also have a Wi-Fi enabled scale
that is made by we things put the
current one that I have is also Nokia
not only does it do weight but it does a
bunch of other things as well and it
even takes your heart rate at the same
time I'll save my blood pressure usually
you're supposed to be inactive for three
minutes and just sit and rest but we're
gonna just see how this works for the
sake of the demo okay
slightly snug press the button to wake
I've just sit still for five minutes
before the measurement but we're just
gonna take it so
hmm well it sounds like it says I have
an elevated blood pressure right now
maybe it's because I'm stressed trying
to shoot a bunch of videos maybe it's
because I'm a little stressed because I
haven't left the house maybe I'm a
little stressed because there's a
pandemic I don't know what could it be
but the good thing is the fact that I
know that this is a little bit high for
me because I've taken my blood pressure
in the past so it's great to be able to
know what my baseline blood pressure
normally is I feel like if I did sit
here for five minutes and stayed calm
and I wasn't filming and trying to get
this video done because it's really late
I think my blood pressure would be a
little lower even if you don't get this
particular one having something like
this at your house just to be able to
take your blood pressure so that you do
know what it is definitely recommend it
doesn't have to be this version you can
get any cup this is just a little
aromatherapy they have so many different
versions of these this one is USB
powered and it's plugged into this
massive Mophie so I have some essential
oils in here I think I haven't
eucalyptus in here right now
oh yeah eucalyptus to just palm ease my
surroundings to lower my blood pressure
a little bit let's use my Apple watch to
take my heart rate so saying my heart
rate is 71
there's tons of different ones of these
this is just one that my mom actually
bought me my favorite essential oils I
love peppermint eucalyptus and lavender
for relaxation I would say probably
eucalyptus is my favorite next up again
having to use the Mophie charger this is
foam soap this is also on backorder but
this isn't thing that my mom got me for
Christmas a few years ago this is an
ultraviolet case to put your phone in
well isn't really a case it's like a
tanning bed microphone so it uses the UV
rays to disinfect your phone it stays in
here for several minutes and when the
light goes off right there you can see
that turned on your phone will be ready
and disinfected I've also been using
this to put my Apple watch in my Apple
pencil and really anything else that you
can fit in here
so clearly the light hasn't gone off yet
but for the sake of the video tada it's
all clean I do this like once a day
usually when I wake up in the morning
because it'll give me a nice clean phone
all day next up we've got this is just a
infrared heating pad I've been obsessed
with infrared tech recently there are
some infrared spas where you can get in
a pod I think I posted this on Instagram
before where I went to an infrared sauna
so you basically go in a pod and detox
you infrared is really great for
inflammation so for me I have a lot of
chronic pain it just kind of runs in my
family so like my normal day-to-day like
I always just have pain it's just a
little bit I've sort of gotten used to
but since I've started using infrared
therapy it's been helping so much so
this is just a very simple heating pad I
use this for my back or you know back
time in a month for cramp perhaps so
this has been awesome
it's easy small portable I can travel
with this but there's also something
else that I got that was too big to even
bring in this room it is an infrared
crystal mat I had it in my Amazon
wishlist and my cart for a really long
time and then a few months ago I finally
decided to get it and it's been really
great I don't know if the crystals
scientifically are doing anything but
for me mentally and spear
actually I'll say they do so this mat
was actually inspired by my friend Joey
Graceffa I'm sure many of you guys have
seen his YouTube channel but I saw he
posted about this as Instagram stories I
asked him about it and he said it was
absolutely awesome there's a bunch of
different sizes but I opted for the
largest one these are used a lot in spas
this is kind of one of those silly
purchases that it was like what was I
thinking but it's pretty great I usually
use it at nights before I go to bed it
does have the same cover that you can
sit on it you know what's not
comfortable laying on thousands of tiny
little crystals has very low
temperatures and something that I didn't
realize when I first got this is that
this is actually in Celsius my heel yet
my parents recently got an infrared
sauna and for them it's been really
great and you never go home for the
holidays I'm always really excited to
use it cuz they have it in their
basement and it's pretty awesome there's
so much more about infrared I really
would love to do an entire video talking
about infrared and maybe talking to some
specialists who know a lot more than I
do about it let me know if that's
something that you guys would like to
see do I have any other tech for you
guys or is that it well I guess I'd
never put my jacket back on but it's
really hot in here cuz clearly I'm a
little warm I would say 99.9 thank you
guys so much for watching
I would love to hear from you guys if
you have any other health tech
suggestions this is something that I
really love exploring and there's so
many other things out there and right
now like I said it is kind of hard to
get some of these things so there are
wait lists or pre-orders for some of
these things and you do have the extra
cash and are looking to get something
like this for your home big now is a
really great time so I'm gonna go and
keep monitoring my temperature and I
think that's the end of the video so see
you later
[Music]